le rem de l'ouest n'est pas encore
achevée et l'europe de l'est ne fait
toujours pas consensus mais un autre est
déjà sur les rails et un dossier où je
veux prendre quelques minutes pour vous
en parler c'est leur hymne 2.0 une ligne
sur la rive-sud qui relierait la station
panama au métro longueuil puis s'en
iraient vers l'est en passant par le
vieux longueuil mais comme à montréal il
y a des préoccupations
je préfère avoir le trait au sol
qu'avant le trait en eau parce que ça se
fait dans les autres pays ça se fait
pourquoi ça se ferait pas ici au canada
ou au québec si c'est des affaires en
route un comme il semble le vouloir
surfer à montréal je suis moins d'accord
mais je pense que katherine va
travailler pour que ça s'intègre et oui
catherine fournier la mairesse a même
déjà obtenu des assurances qui a un
comité qui a été mise sur pied par la
caisse qui va nous faire certaines
propositions longueuil entend exclure un
raid aérien sur une portion de près de 2
km on a des bonnes discussions sur ce
plan là pour voir de quelle façon on
peut développer leur m mais au seul pour
que ça fait ça aime beaucoup plus
harmonieux ce qu'on doit retenir de
psychodrame de l'est en fait il doit y
avoir un véritable collaboration
et françois legault anticipe déjà les
critiques concernant les futurs portion
aérienne d'abord on parle du btan c'est
possible de peinture et humble un pic de
d'intégrer ces structures locales sont
en hauteur pour que ça soit beau
maintenant il ya des solutions aussi
pour ce qui est du filage la rtm dino
siéger qu'un comité qui n'est pas
décisionnel sur ce projet le réseau de
transport de longueuil est sans
nouvelles de la caisse à qui il a
transmis une somme d'informations sur un
réseau de transport structurants quant à
cdpq a failli nous indique que les
études dont on parle ne sont que
préliminaires ici mathieu prost radio
canada longueuil